hello I'm a citizen and I'm the  government so do you work for me or are  you like my dad just think of me as the  things that we do together together  hello I'm a citizen and I'm the  government  hey it's tax season how much do I owe  you guys oh you have to figure that out  for yourself do you know how much I owe  you  oh yeah we know but we're not gonna tell  you you have to figure it out what  happens if I get it wrong well then you  always more and you might go to prison  hello I'm a citizen and I'm the  government hey you guys outlawed  marijuana yes it is worse than cocaine  can I see some studies to back that up  you know it's real hard to find  scientific studies than that kind of  subject because you outlawed it yes it  is worse than cocaine hello I'm a  citizen and I'm the government Hey  social distancing see if you'd resolve  those testing issues sorry I don't know  which ones you're talking about  [Music]  [Music]